CARLA: Hi, everyone.
Good morning.
My name is Carla.
I'm going to be talking about
a very fundamental concept
in aerodynamics.
But before I start, have you
all gone in planes before?
Yeah?
OK.
Have you wondered, how does
the pilot land the plane?
A little?
All right.
I'm going to explain
two concepts that
will help you understand how
you actually land the plane.
And these concepts are the
concepts of lift and angle
of attack.
So I want you to picture a
plane going through the skies.
And in real life, the planes
don't fly perfectly horizontal.
They actually fly at an angle.
And we're going to draw a
little plane going at an angle.
And this angle between the
horizontal and the plane--
it's going to be known as
alpha, the angle of attack.
And it's usually
about 10 degrees.
So that's why it seems
that you're going uphill
when you walk across a plane.
Now, there are two forces
acting on the plane.
You're going to have gravity--
the weight of the plane,
pulling the weight down.
And you're going to also
have a force upwards that's
keeping the plane afloat.
And that force is called lift,
which we're going to note by L.
Lift is generated as air
rushes through the wings.
The wings are
designed in such a way
that as air goes
through them, they're
going to generate
a force upwards.
So that's what keeps
the plane uplift.
Now, there's a
relationship between lift
and the angle of attack.
And I'm going to illustrate
it in the following plot.
So we're going to
have-- on the x-axis I'm
going to have the angle
of attack, in degrees.
And then for the
y-axis, I'm going
to have the lift,
which is a force
and therefore has
units of Newtons.
Now, it is known that at
small angles of attack,
if you increase the angle
of attack a little bit,
you're going to get more lift.
So if you increase
it a little bit,
you're going to get more lift.
So you're going to
get an upwards trend
in the first part of the plot.
Now, it might be that you have
a very high angle of attack--
that the plane's going
actually really steep.
The flow is going to be
quite adverse to the wings
and they're going to
stop generating lift.
So if you make the
angle even steeper,
you're going to
get even less lift.
So that means that in
this part of the plot,
at very high angles
of attack, you're
going to get even less lift
as you increase the angle.
Yes there's a question.
STUDENT 1: By extreme
angles, do you
mean like, greater that 45
degrees or like 10 degrees?
CARLA: Greater than 15
actually-- greater than 15.
So you have these two regimes.
And there's this mode of
transition in between.
And the maximum
occurs at 15 degrees.
And this condition at which
the plane starts to lose lift
is known as a stall.
So when an airplane starts
to lose lift, it stalls.
Now airplanes usually
fly about 10 degrees.
You want the angle
of attack to be high,
so that you get a
lot of lift, but not
so high that you will stall.
So to land the plane, what
does a pilot actually do?
Here approaches the runways at
10 degrees, the normal angle.
And when he's about
to hit the ground,
he changes the angle of attack
to 15 degrees and stalls.
So they lose a lot of lift and
they actually crash the plane,
gently to the ground.
All right.
Are there any questions?
Yes.
STUDENT 2: Do the
aerodynamics of the plane
affect the stall point?
CARLA: They do.
The stall point
depends on the velocity
of the plane-- which
the plane's going at,
and the shape of the wings.
But it's usually around 15
degrees for any sort of plane.
There are planes-- the one
that actually can fly vertical,
those ones have other
sorts of control.
The winds are stalling but
they have fancy motors that
can hold that angle.
There was another question.
No?
Yes.
Yes, what's the question?
STUDENT 3: Are the wings
also angled with respect
to the plane?
CARLA: Sorry.
Could you be a
little louder please?
Could you repeat
the question please?
STUDENT 3: Are the wings
also angled with respect
to the plane?
CARLA: Yes, yes, yes.
So the question is if the wings
have an angle with respect
to the plane.
And yes they do.
The plane moves
something like this,
and the wings are
at a small angle
of 2 to 3 degrees with respect
to the horizontal of the plane.
I'm exaggerating it, but
it is at a small angle.
But then the cross-section
actually changes.
And if you look at the
airplane from the front,
the wings are actually doing
something like this here.
So there's a number of angles
going on with the plane.